وفي عناوين هذه الساعه من التغطيه
فاليوم الرابع لكارثه الزلزال السلطات
المغربيه تعلن ارتفاع عدد الضحايا الى
1862 قتيله واكثر من
2500 مصاب وجهود متسارعه لفتح الطرق سعيا
لبلوغ المناطق المعزوله
عمليات الاغاثه تتجه لاعانه الاف
المتضررين وايوائهم ارسالوا مجموعات طبيه
ودعم اللوجستيه برا وجوا للمناطق المنقوبه
والحكومه المغربيه تكشف عن برنامج لتعويض
و ايواء من فقدوا مساكنهم جراء الزلزال
مئات القتلى جراء الاعصار والسيول شرقيه
ليبيا وتقارير تتحدث عن الاف المفقودين
والمجلس البلدي لمدينه درنه يطلب تدخلا
دوليا عاجلا ويقول ان احياء سكنيه باكملها
غرقت بعد انهيار سدين ودبيبه يعلن
البلديات المتضرره مناطق منكوبه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه التغطيه المستمره
الجهود اذا مستمره سائلا للوصول الى احياء
تحت الركام في المغرب في اليوم الرابع
اعلنت الداخليه المغربيه ان عدد القتلى
ارتفع الى
282 قتيلا والمصابين الى 2000 وخمسمائه
فرق الانقاذ تسابق الزمن لانقاذ ما من
يمكن وانقاذه وسط تحديات ابرزها فتح الطرق
المقطوعه التي تحول دون الوصول الى بعض
المناطق المنكوبه
ولتفاصيل اكثر نذهب الان الى عثمان اي فرح
وجوله مع مرسلين على الارض هناك اذا عثمان
الصوره من خلفك تقول كل شيء لكن ليله
رابعه يبيتها المنكوبون في اكثر المناطق
التضررا
نعم زينه صوره خلفي تشبه الصوره في اماكن
كثيره ركام هذه المباني
المتهدمه وكما ذكرت اهم الصعوبات
والعراقيل يتعلق بايصال المساعدات بسبب
وعوره الطرق احيانا كثيره يكون الطريق
الجبليا ضيقا في مسار واحد وبه انهيارات
جبليه وترابيه وبالتالي تتراكم الصخور في
هذا الطريق الواح ادوا يجب اولا ازاله هذا
الركام وهو عمليه بالغه الصعوبه حتى يتم
الوصول الى المناطق النائيه وما يسمى هنا
بالدواوير او التجمعات السكنيه الصغيره
المعزوله وبالتالي القوات المسلحه
تسعى من خلال
الطيارات الى
معذره تسعى الى القاء المساعدات سواء من
الاغذيه او الغذاء الى هذه الاماكن
الزملاء المراسلون سيحدثوننا اكثر عن هذه
الصعوبات في اماكن مثل الشيشاوه قريه
تولكين يوجد فيها عمر الحاج
ومعنا من ورزازات سيف الدين بوعلاق سعيد
بوخفه في اقليم الحوز في الطريق تحديدا
بين مراكش واسمي وفي اثني يوجد المختار
العلاوي ولكن سابدا بك عمر في شيشاوه
ومعروفه بصعوبه ووعوره هذه الطرق وهذا
يشكل لعائقا كبيرا
وحقيقيا للوصول الى من يحتاجون المساعده
ولنبدا منها الزميل للمصور
سياريكم هذا هذا واحد من اختناقات
المروريه التي
عشناها منذ الصباح كما حدثتك في مراسلات
سابقه عن ان طريقا بطول 120 او 130 كيلو
متر سيكلفك اكثر من اربع ساعات او خمس
ساعات هذا هو مدخل بلده مزمز
بشكل صحيح هذه واحده من اكثر المدن
الكبيره ليست ليست دوارا قضيعه وليست قريه
بلديه مدينه الى كبيره كانت قريبه من مركز
الزلزال وقع فيها ضحايا كثيره كثر وهي خط
الواصل بين كل المدن الواقعه على
البلدات او الضياع الواقعه على سفوح
الجبال التي مررنا عليها هذا هو كما ذكرت
نهايه الخط الذي يوصل المدن وتحديدا
بباقي انقر ايضا المشهد حولي
على اليمين بعض الاثار الزلزال التي تعرضت
لها المدينه وخلف المصور هناك تجمع لبعض
الاهالي الذين سيبيتون في العراق مشاركين
هذا الخيار او ربما الاجبار مع من حولك في
مراكش وفي مناطق اخرى حقيقه
تحدثنا عن تنظيم في ارسال مساعدات ولكن
عثمان هذا الامر لما يضبط
بشكل كامل بعد
صدقني من اخر نشره حتى الان اكثر من
ساعتين قضيناها في الطريق حتى نصل لانه
هناك الكثير من الناس الذين هبوا للمساعده
ولكن العوده ستكلف الكثيره من الوقت ولكن
لابد من الاشاره الى ان الاعداد كانت
كبيره المساهمات كانت كبيره بالمناسبه في
اخر مكان في تركيا حيث كنا هناك
بدا في انشاء مشفى ميداني في تلك المنطقه
حتى يسهل على الفرق الطبيه وحتى يسهل على
المرضى الذين الان ينتشرون في السفوح وفي
الخيم التي رصدناها ورصدها الزملاء حيث
حيث سيبقى لهؤلاء الى هذه المشفى بعد ذلك
حسب الحاجه الى المشافي الكبرى
نعم هذا في شيشاوه سعيد انت ايضا يمكنك ان
تتحدث عن مساله صعوبه الطريق هذه وقد كنت
في الطريق
واقتربت كثيرا من بؤره الزلزال في المنطقه
الجبليه هناك والطرق وعره وصعبه ويمكن
القول انها ايضا خطيره
عثمان ربما ما جاء على هذه الطرق اكثر
خطوره واكثر اكتضاضا هو حجم السيارات التي
لم تتعود هذه الطريق عليها الطريق جبليه
كانت عاده يستخدمها اصحاب هذه او سكان هذه
القرى المجاوره
عفوا لمراكش فكانت سيارات نقل تسمى هنا في
المنطقه بالنقل المزدوج اي نقل الاشخاص
ونقل البضائع فكانت هذه الطريق ربما لا
تحتمل هذا الكم من السيارات توقفنا في هذه
الطريق بين اسني وطريق المؤديه الى مراكش
سالنا الناس يتحدثون على انهم لم يعتادوا
على هذه الحركه وحركه المرور الموجوده هنا
حاليا وفعلا حركه مرور
يعني في اكتظاظ هناك اكتظاظ على هذا
المحور وكذلك الطرق ضيقه وجبليه خاصه كما
قلت عندما تقترب من الجبل حيث كانت بؤره
الزلزال هناك تصبح الطريق صعبه مع
الانهيارات الصخريه ايضا التي في طريقنا
شاهدنا بعض المحاولات لازاله الاقل الصخور
الصغيره
بالايدي وكذلك بالمجاري في اليدويه ربما
لتسهيل مرور الطرق شاهدنا مواكب كان يضطر
سائقوا السيارات فيها الى النزول والجرف
الطريق بايديهم للمرور وايصال المساعدات
سيارات الاسعاف التي شاهدتها اليوم
تتجاوز اربعين سياره اسعاف بعضها خصص لنقل
المرضى وخاصه الاطفال الا لنا ان الاطفال
هم الذين تعرضوا لاصابات اكثر خاصه في
ورقان فهذه السيارات نقلت بعض الاطفال الى
المستشفيات في المراكز الحضريه المراكز
الحضريه
هنا المدن والقرى التي تكون فيها كثافه
سكانيه وتكون فيها مستشفيات ومراكز للعلاج
لاحظنا ايضا العديد من
الناس والاهالي في طريقنا على طول الطريق
اغلقوا محلهم التجاريه وعندما سالنا قالوا
انهم الان لا يريدون ان يمارسوا اي نشاط
تجاري بل همهم الان هو الانتقال الى
المناطق المجاوره والى سفوح الجبل
للمساعده سواء سواعدهم في
الجرف الاتربه والانهيارات والبحث عن
الجثث لان الان اليوم الرابع واليوم
الخامس
ربما
تتضاءل العمل في ايجاد احياء تحت الانقاض
فهؤلاء يحاولون بما يملكون وبعض المحل
التجاريه ايضا قالوا بانهم اخذوا بعض
المواد الغذائيه معهم الى المنكوبين
والمتضررين خاصه في وركان التي شهدت فقط
اخيرا الفريق الخاص التابع للقوات المسلحه
المغربيه الذي كان يعمل ووكبناه منذ
الصباح سينتقل غدا فجرا سيستريح الليله
وينتقل غدا فجرا الى ثلاث يعقوب التي
سنتوجه الى اليها ايضا غدا صباحا للوقوف
على حجم الدمار هنا اليكم عثمان
نعم قريه ثلاثه يعقوب هي من الاماكن التي
يعني تعتبر تقريبا هي بؤره الزلزال بالقرب
من اغيل في اقليم الحوز اذا المختار
والطريق هناك طريق الى هناك صعبه للغايه
بلا شك يعني
والمختار العملاوي ليس بعيدا عن المكان
الذي يوجد فيه سعيد بوخفه هو موجود في
اثني تحديدا ومع تراجع درجات الحراره
واتجاه الطقس الى ان يكون ابرد الخيام
اولويه كبيره ليست كذلك خيام الايواء
المؤقته المختار
نعم بالفعل عثمان درجات الحراره بدات
تنخفض تدريجيا خلال ساعات النهار كانت
هناك درجات حراره مرتفعه لكن عمليا الان
مع التقدم نحو نهايه السنه دخول الخريف
وبعد ذلك فصل الشتاء بدا درجات الحراره
تنخفض ولاحظ السكان هنا سكان هذه المناطق
ان درجه الحراره بدات مع تزايد الايام
خصوصا ونحن في منطقه جبليه اقليم الحوزوه
احد اكبر الاقاليم المغربيه من حيث
التضاريس الجبليه
بعد وقوع الزلزال وانهيار المنازل اما
بشكل جزئي او بشكل كلي اضطر الناس الى
افتراش الارض البعض استفاد من الخيام التي
قدمتها سلطاتها المحليه البعض استفاده من
القيام التي قدمتها بعض الجمعيات والبعض
الاخر ترك منزله بالنظر الى وجود الشقوق
او بالنظر الى الانهيار الكلي وافترش
العراء كما سنشاهد الان حيث هذه الاسر
افترشت الارض واستعانه بالاشجار في انتظار
وجود حلول بديله هذه الاسراء الان بدات
هذا الواقع الجديد الى حدود ايام قليله
كانت تتوفر على منازل لها لكن تغير الحال
وبات لهم واقع اخر هذا الواقع فيه الكثير
من المعاناه وواقع قلبه في الحقيقه حياتهم
راسا على عقب نشاهد هنا بعض التجهيزات
البسيطه التي يستعلون بها في سبيل تطعيم
افراد الاسر لديهم النساء لديهم اطفال
صغار وواقع يعبر عن نفسه كما
تنقل الصوره الان لدينا الحاجه
فاطمه مرحبا بك لحظه الزلزال كيف كانت
لحظه الزلزال وماذا كنت تفعلين
بنتي
والمنزل
ديالو كلشي
فيها
الحمد لله
اذا هذه هي الاسره الان تعيش في هذا
الواقع لكن من اجل ايجاد حلول الجمعيه لا
ادري اين هو الباب نعم هذا الباب موجود في
الاتجاه افراد
الدوار قاموا بمبادره سنشاهدها الان هذه
المبادره هي اقامه هذه الخيمه التي نشاهد
خيمه تم نسبها قبل قليل لنقل هؤلاء النساء
الى هذه الخيمه في ظل كما قلنا قبل قليل
ارتفاع الكفار درجات الحراره احد الشباب
الناشطين الذين قاموا بهذه المباراه
المبادره سيقدم لنا فكره بسيطه لماذا تم
شي من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى ومرحبا
لجميع الله مرحبا
الحمد لله احنا في هذه البلاصه مازال ما
قدرنا ندخلوا للديور الديور باقي
عليهم الدار وما قدروش يدخلوا للديار
ودرنا هذه بقينا هنايا حتى ان شاء الله
مرحبا به وهذا الشيء
الله سبحانه وتعالى والحمد لله اللي جاي
مرحبا والناس اتفقوا بيناتهم وجالسين
قسم الله كتجمعوا الناس العيال في البلاصه
واحنا الحمد لله اتفقنا بيناتنا
اذا هي مبادره قام بها سكان هذه الدوار
مبادره من الشباب وايضا مختلف الشرائح
المجتمعيه في هذا الدوار من اجل المساعده
في تخفيف نعم الواقع الذي يعاني منه
السكان خصوصا نعم المختار الانهيارات
سننتقل الى ورزازات الاسيف الدين بوعلاق
سيف انت موجود في ورزازات طبعا المدينه في
داخل المدينه تحديدا لم تتاثر كثيرا ولكن
الدمار لاحق
بالبلدات
المحيطه بورزازات حدثنا عن جهود
الاغاثه والمساعده
والتضامن من من قلب المدينه حيث توجد ان
هناك في ورزازات
نعم ادعم عثمان في الحقيقه انا مثل شرط في
قلب مدينه ورزازات المدينه لم تتاثر بهذا
الزلزال بشكل كبير ولكن القرى المحيطه
بورزازات كانت قد تاثرت بشكل كبير وفقدت
ورزازات واحد واربعين شخصا من ابنائها
اكيد عثمان انت والزملاء تحدثوا منذ قليل
عن الطرق المقطوعه التي تسبب بها الزلزال
نتيجه الكتله الترابيه والصخريه والتي
عقدت
عقدت عمليه الاغاثه وايصال المساعدات
واجلاء المصابين هذا ما قام ما قام به
الزلزال اي غضب الطبيعه ولكن ايضا هناك
طرق اخرى فتحت طرق نحو الانسانيه عثمان في
الحقيقه نحن نتعلم في كل لحظه من مما يحدث
هنا في المغرب حقيقه هناك مبادرات في
التازر وفي التكافل وفي التعاون يعني ما
مسائل انسانيه قويه ومعبره جدا مثلا في
هذا المكان عثمان تلاحظ معي هذه مبادره
عفويه بدا انت اطلقها مجموعه من الشباب
لجمع التبرعات للقرى التي تضررت من
الزلزال تضررت من البنيه التحتيه واصبح
سكانها بحاجه الى اي نوع من انواع
المساعدات تلاحظ معي جميعهم من الشباب
يجمعون التبرعات الماديه والعينيه ايضا
وما يحتاجه ما تحتاجه الكره المنكوبه في
المحيطه
بورزازات يعني يجمعون الماء والحليب
والمواد الغذائيه وايضا سيريكم محمد يعني
شاحنه كامله من الاغذيه تم جمعها من عبر
هذه المبادره العفويه
ساتحدث ايضا عن مساله الانسانيه ولملمه
الجراح عثمان
يعني هذه المبادره تلقها مجموعه من الشباب
وعلى راسهم الشاب معنا هو مصطفى مصطفى فقد
جدته وجده وعنبته في هذا الزلزال ولكن لم
يقف ربما او لم يستسلم للجراح وللمشاعر
الانسانيه الطبيعيه ولكنه اطلق هذه
المبادره وسيحدثنا عثمان مصطفى عن هذه
المبادره مرحبا بك اولا رحم الله
فقط وشفاء الله الجرح لو تحدثنا اولا عما
اصاب العائله وايضا عن هذه المبادره مصطفى
اولا شكرا لكم على حضور مدينه ورزازات
اول شيء نتمنى من الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يرحم جميع موتى الزلزال المدمر
ان يلطف الله بالعقارب الذين يعني هناك
عائله فقدوا العديد من من افراد اسرتهم
نسال الله تعالى ان يرحمهم
والحمد لله كارثه
كانت كبيره جدا والعديد من الدواوير واكيد
حتى في المدن المنازل الهشه في مدينه
ورزازات تعرضت ايضا لانهيار ومنازل قابله
للانهيار ايضا
عن تجربتك الشخصيه اعرف انها تجربه ولكن
لابد ان نتحدث عنها نعم تجربه كانت قاسيه
بحكم تقريبا هي الاولى يعني بهذه القوه
والهلع والرعب الذي عاشره لست فقط وحدي
يعني كثير من المواطنين
والاطفال والشيوخ والنساء لحظات عصيبه
كانت
مرعبه في الختام هذه المبادره في في وقت
مختصر لو سمحت المبادره هي عباره عن نصف
الاول ونصف الاخير ولست وحدي يعني هي
مبادرات من من ابناء الشعب من المواطنين
يعني الكل يساهم الكل يساعد سواء ماديا
سواء معنويا سواء بالمواد سواء
بالنقل ايضا يعني اناس يوفرون سياراتهم
مناسبه فرن شاحناتهم ونسال الله تعالى ان
تقبل من الجميع ونحن في مواكبه السلطات
ايضا بالتوفيق بالتوفيق بالتوفيق مصطفى
شكرا لك عثمان هذا هو المشهد هذه هي ربما
هذا منتهى الانسانيه كما لاحقت وعينت
وشاهدت عثمان نعم
نعم سيف والحقيقه جميل جدا ما قلته طرق
كثيره اغلقت او هي مغلقه ولكن طرق كثيره
اخرى فتحت طرق انسانيه وهذا هو الجانب
المشرق الذي نشاهده في هذه الكارثه اشخاص
مثل مصطفى ومثل الشاب الذي شاهدناه في
نافذه سابقه مع المختار في اقليم الحوز
هؤلاء المتضررون الذين فقدوا احبتهم
واقاربهم وذويهم ولكنهم بكل رباطه جاش
وضعوا احزانهم جانبا ليساعدوا الاخرين
شكرا لك سيف الدين بوعلاق من غرزازات وكان
معنا من قريه توركين في شيشاوه عمر الحاج
وايضا من اسن في اقليم الحوز المختار
العدلاوي وفي المنطقه الواقعه في الطريق
بين اسمي ومراكش سعيد بوخفه التغطيه اذا
مستمره
ونعود لمتابعتها معك بالحصاد زين
شكرا لك عثمان وما زلنا في تغطيتنا لهذا
الزلزال وكشف رئيس الحكومه المغربيه عزيزه
اخنوش عن برنامج لتعويض من دمرت منازلهم
او تضررت بسبب الزلزال قال اخنوشي ان
البرنامج سيكون جاهزا خلال الايام وسيتضمن
ايضا اجراءات للاواء المؤقت للمتضررين
غادي يكون عرض احد العرض غادي يحاولوا
نوجدوه داخل هذا الاسبوع ان شاء الله واضح
وفي هذه الايام الجايه ان شاء الله عن
قريب غادي نعلمو على هذا العرض بالنسبه
للمواطنين
كذلك انه في هاد كاين واحد العدد ديال
التساؤلات انه الناس اليوم ما عندهاش
السكنى
نحاولو باش كذلك يعني
بعض الحلول اللي يهمون المواطنين
هذا يسابق الرجال لانقاذ في المغرب الزمر
للعثور على احياء وتقديم المساعده لمئات
ممن فقدوا منازلهم بعد ثلاثه ايام من
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب قرى اقليم الحوز
يوم الجمعه الماضي
الامل على سفوح جبال الاطلس لكنه لا
يتلاشى تماما بالعثور على احياء تحت
الركام
صحيح ان مرور الساعات يعني ارتفاع عدد
الموتى غير ان تكثيف فرق الانقاذ المغربيه
عمليات البحث وتوسيعها يعزز الامال بنجاه
عالقين
هذه الكتل الصخريه الضخمه المنهاره لا
تزعزع ثقه الاهالي في رؤيه احبائهم احياء
يرزقون وتلك رغبه يتقاسمها معهم افراد فرق
الانقاذ انفسهم ولاولئك وهؤلاء في زلزال
تركيا وسوريا قصص نجاه ملهمه
سباق محموم مع الزمن تخوده فرق لانقاذ
المغربيه ومعها منقذون عرب ودوليون مجهزون
بمعدات كشف وكاميرات لاختراق فجوات صغيره
بين الركام تساعدهم كلاب مدربه لاكتشاف
الجثث والاحياء لكن جهود الالقاء تصطدم
بعقبات هائله فبعض القرى الجبليه المنكوبه
لا يمكن للسيارات الوصول اليها وحتى
المروحيات لا تستطيع الهبوط في بعضها بسبب
الارتفاعات الشاهقه والتضاريس الوعره
ويعني ذلك تعذر اجلاء الذين يتم انقاذهم
الى المستشفيات الكبرى لتلقي العلاج
اللازم كما ان استخدام الجرافات والرافعات
يفاقم خطر الانهيارات الصخريه وقد يقضي
على احياء مفترضين تحت الانقاض ما يجعل
العمل اليدوي باستخدام المعاول اكثر امانا
لكن بطئا ايضا في اوضاع يعد فيها الوقت
بالثواني والدقائق الحياه في بعض القرى
انتهت تقريبا فالمباني الطينيه سويت
بالارض وتكاد مهمه فرق الانقاذ تنحصر
بانتشال الجثث خصوصا في قرى اقليم الحوز
مركز الزلزال حيث سجل اكثر من نصف القتلى
اما الناجون من الكارثه فالى الم الفقد
ووقع الصدمه تضاف فصول اخرى من المعاناه
هذه خيم اقامتها السلطات على عجل كمراكز
ايواء طارئه على الطرق وعلى تخوم المناطق
المنكوبه تتظافر هنا جهود الدفاع المدني
والجيش ومنظمات غير حكوميه في المغرب
لاحتواء الموقف غير ان الاحتياجات تتعاظم
وعامل الوقت يضغط اكثر فاكثر مع قرب حلول
فصل الشتاء في تلك المناطق الجبليه
النائيه المحتاجه لانشاء مساكن لائقه تؤوي
الاهالي وتقيهم قرا بات على الابواب
هذا ووصل الطائره قطريه للمغرب على متنها
مساعدته الانسانيه وفريقه انقاذ قطري
للمشاركه في جهود الاغاثه في المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال وقال الرائد خالد عبد
الله الحميدي قائد فريق الانقاذ القطري ان
حضور الفريق جاء بعد تنسيق مسبق وتواصل مع
الجانب المغربي مضيفنا لافراد الفريق
القطري سيعملون كمساعدين للطواقم المغربيه
في موقعين بناء على ما تم الاتفاق عليه
عبر قنوات تواصل وتنسيق مع الجانب المغربي
كما بدات وحده الطوارئ التابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاسبانيه عملها في مدينه مدينه
زيمز في اقليم الحوز للعثور على ماجينا من
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه ونبه رئيس
الفريق الاسباني انطونيو جالس الى ان
المساكن المتضرره من الزلزال مبنيه من
الطوب الطيني والحجر والخشب وهو ما يقلل
من فرص العثور على ناجين ويشار الى ان
الفريق الاسبانيه يتالف من 56 فرده وهو
مزود باربعه كلاب مدربه للمساعده في جهود
البحث والانقاذ
تعرقل التضاريس الواعره في هذه المنطقه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ في مناطق واسعه
ضربها الزلزال في المغرب اتعرف اكثر على
هذه الازمه في هذا التقرير
بين هذه الجبال سبع درجات على مقياس رختر
وصلت تاثيراتها على بعد 400 كيلو متر في
محيط المكان في المنطقه القريبه من ايغيل
بلده اديسيل تتبع اقليم شيشاوه المجاور
لكنها قريبه للغايه من مركز الزلزال قريه
جبليه سويت بالكامل وقطعت الانهيارات
الصخريه الطرق المؤديه اليها وتحولت الى
مثال حي للماساه يعقد الوضع في شيشاوه
بشكل عام المشهد في محيط مركز الزلزال
يعتبر الاقليم بموقعه الجغرافي ممرا
ضروريا لمناطق جنوب المغرب وغربا باتجاه
الصويره لكن على بعد 80 كيلومترا جنوبا من
مركز الزلزال يتكرر الضرر تارد انت مدينه
تلتقي فيها سلسله جبال الاطلس الصغير
والاطلس الكبير يتسبب الزلزال في حدوث
انهيارات صخريه في تارودانت كغيرها من
القرى الجبليه فدمر بعضها بشكل شبهي كامل
انهارت جل المباني الطينيه وتسبب الزلزال
في قطع الطرق بسبب الانهيارات الصخريه
وتعقدت عمليات الانقاذ تتعقد عمليات
الانقاذ ولا تتوقف ولا يتوقف الامل في
وجود ناجين
الينا من الرباط تفاوت بالعيد مديره
البرامج في منظمه اكشن الدوليه للاغاثه
سيد بلعيد اهلا وسهلا بك
في ظل هذه الظروف التي تحدثنا عنها الخاصه
بالطبيعه الجغرافيه
وبقوه الزلزال وبانتشار الجيش في مناطق
المناطق المنقوبه ما هي المساحه المتاحه
للمجتمع المدني والجمعيات الاهليه
كجمعياتكم للمساهمه في اسعاف وانقاذ
واعانه المنكوبين
اوكي شكرا اولا اود ان اشكر طاقمكم على
الدعوه وكل من ارسل دعمه ودعواته لاخواتنا
واخواننا المغاربه المتضررين من هذه
الفاجعه اما بعد
واجابه عن سؤالكم بالنسبه الى هذا الزلزال
ومنذ ان حصل كان هناك استجابه اوليه منذ
الحكومه المغربيه لاننا شاهدنا انتشارا
واسعا نطاق للقوات المسلحه والسلطات
المحليه والمنظمات المحليه التي بدات
بعمليه البحث
والانقاذ ومنذ حصل هذا الزلزال حصل طبعا
هذا الزلزال في منطقه محدده وهي منطقه
جبليه كما قلنا وهناك طرق صغيره وعره
معروفه بان فيها انزلاقات كبيره للتربه
وهناك منا بعيده وهذا ما صعد جهود الاغاثه
والبحث والانقاذ ولكن الحمد لله ان هذه
الجهود تستمر ولا نزال نبحث عن الناس
وهناك اشخاص منكوبين وعدد كبير من الناس
حصل على معاناه غذائيه ومن الامور
الاساسيه من مثل الخيام التي وزعت على
المنكوبين لكي يتمكنوا من البقاء في
لك المكان
ونتحدث عن مستوصفات او مستشفيات مؤقته
التي تقدم
الاعانات الطبيه والمساعده الطبيه الاوليه
بالنسبه الى المنظمات الدوليه هناك
مساعدات بدات من خلال جمع التبرعات في
الخارج هو ارسالها الينا بالتعاون مع
المنظمات المحليه للتوزيع هذا لتوزيع
المساعدات على الاشخاص الذين تضرروا باسرع
طريقه ممكنه وعلى مستوى اكشن كان لدينا
اهتمام بشكل اساسي بهذه النقطه مساله
الماوى لاننا نتحدث عن المجموعات لانه
احنا نتحدث عن عمليه اغاثه كبيره يقوم بها
الجيش
والسلطات الرسميه كيف يتم التنسيق بين
المنظمات الاهليه سواء كانت دوليه او
محليه
لايصال هذه التبرعات الى مستحقيه
بالنسبه الى نحن نعمل مع شركاء المحليين
من منظمات المحليه عملنا معها لتقييم اثر
الزلزال وبشكل سريع تم العمل على تحديد
الاماكن التي هي بامس الحاجه والاحتياجات
المنتشره في تلك المناطق الاساسيه
ونتحدث عن احتياجات اساسيه من مثل الغذاء
والماكل المشرب
مساعدات الاوليه الاساسيه التي ارسلت
ووزعت على المنكوبين في تلك المناطق التي
تاثرت بشكل كبير وشركائه المحليين تمكنوا
من الوصول اليهم هل اجيب عن سؤالك
تقريبا شكرا جزيلا لك على اي الاحوال
انتهى وقتنا للاسف سيده دفاعه بالعيد
مديره البرامج في منظمه اكشن ايد الدوليه
للغايه ضيفتنا من الرباط
ومن كاليفورنيا ينضم الينا المهندس
كيتسو خبير الانشاءات والكوارث ورئيس
منظمه
للحد من مخاطر الزلازل بدايه ملاحظاتك
على هذا الزلزال زلزال الحوس على الابنيه
التي تعرضت للدمار وايضا على المنطقه
وطبيعه التربه في المنطقه التي وقع فيها
الزلزال
بكل تاكيد
المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال
لنتحدث عن منطقه جبليه بشكل كبير وبالتالي
نتحدث عن 800 الف شخص تاثروا بهذا الزلزال
ونحن نقدر انه هناك 60 الف مبنى
تاثر وبناء على التجارب السابقه نحن نعرف
20 بالمئه تكون قد تاثرت بشكل كبير
وانهارت
وثلاثه الى اربعه فيها ضرر اذا نحن نتحدث
عن حوالي 50% من المباني التي تاثرت بشكل
اساسي
ونتحدث عن اربع مئه الف شخص قد تاثروا
بالتالي ولذلك بحسب تقديراتنا هناك 400
الف الى 500 الف شخص
تعرضوا لخطر النزوح وهي مساله اساسيه
لاننا نتحدث عن مباني قد تضررت وبحاجه الى
المساعدات في تلك المنطقه
بالنسبه هذه تفضل
المباني التي نشاهدها في تلك المنطقه
الجبليه
لاحظنا انه اذا ما كانت مبنيه بشكل جيد
لديها اسس جيده يمكنها ان
تصمد في مواجهه هذه التحديات ولكن في حال
لم يكن البناء جيدا نشهد الانهيارات اذا
لدينا فريق في مراكش الان وسوف يذهب الى
المناطق النائيه والبلدات لتقييم الاثر
والعمل على اعاده البناء وايضا الترميم
بالنسبه الى المباني لكي تكون جاهزه
لاستقبال الناس الى اي مدى من طبيعه هذه
المباني الى اي مدى ساهمت هذه الطبيعه
لهذه المباني وهي مباني طينيه صخريه خشبيه
كما جاء في التقرير قبل قليل الى اي مدى
ساهمت في
زياره او تقليل من اثر الكارثه هل ساهمت
في زياده عدد الضحايا ام ساهمت في قله عدد
الضحايا
على سبيل المثال هذه
المباني الطينيه
السماكه فيها مهمه طبعا اذا ما كانت اقل
سماكه تكون اكثر خطوره اذا ما كانت
السماكه مرتفعه هذا جيد وايضا كيفيه
التفاعل مع المياه وهو ما يمنع التاكل
المواد الاساسيه بالاضافه الى السطوح اذا
ما كانت خشبيه مبنيه بشكل جيد لتكون
مقاومه بشكل جيد امور بسيطه تصنع فرقا
كبيرا وطبعا هناك طرق تقليديه اساسيه
مستخدمه في البناء اذا ما تمت بشكل جيد
تؤدي الى مباني فيها مستويات مرتفعه من
السلام طبعا اليابان مثال للعالم في مساله
المباني ما الفرق بين مباني اليابان
لسمه في المناطق الج بليه
وانا لا اتحدث عن المباني الكبيره
والبنيات الشاهقه نتحدث عن المباني
العاديه المنزل الذي يكون طابقا او طابقين
ما الفارق بين هذه المنازل ولماذا تصمت في
بلدك اليابان ولا تصمت في بلدان اخرى
اليابان فيه وضع مختلف لان المباني بشكل
اساسي مصنوعه من الخشب وفي كاليفورنيا
كذلك بالنسبه الى المباني الخشبيه هي
تتفاعل بشكل افضل بكثير لانها خفيفه من
حيث الوزن المباني الخفيفه من حيث الوزن
لا تتاثر بمستويات مرتفعه بالاهتزازات
التي تتحرك الارض من خلالها تحتها ونتحدث
في كل خمس سنوات الى عشر سنوات هناك هزات
ارضيه
بوتيره مرتفعه وهذا ما يفرض على الجهات
المطوره للمباني ان تعمل بشكل افضل لتحسين
جوده المباني لكي تكون مقاومه للزلازل
وهذا هو الفرق الاساسي اما بالنسبه الى
المغرب في تلك المنطقه لم يحدث زلزال
مشابه حتى منذ اكثر من 100 عام وهو فرق
الاساسي لو كانت منطقه معرضه بشكل مستمر
طبعا لكانت الاجراءات مغايره شكرا لكن
لذلك من الاهميه في مكان ان نستخلص العبر
لكي نعرف كيفيه البناء في تلك المناطق لكي
تكون المباني
هو زلزال فجاه حتى
المتخصصين في علم الزلازل نظرا لانه وقع
في منطقه لم تقع في هذه منذ اكثر من مئه
عام بهذه الصوره كما انه ليس على الحد
الفاصل بين الصفائح التكتونيه ولكن داخل
الصفيحه ذاتيه لكن نشكرك من كاليفورنيا
المهندس خبير الانشاءات والكوارث ورئيس
منظمه للحد من مخاطر الزلازل ضيفنا من
كاليفورنيا
الى ليبيا تعيش ايضا مدن الشرق فيها تحت
وطاطه كارثه انسانيه بسبب سيول الوفيضانات
كانت من تداعيات الاعصار دانيال واسفرت
حسب حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عند حايا
بالمئات بينما قال رئيس الحكومه المعينه
من البرلمان في شرق ليبيا عدد الضحايا
يبلغ الفين مع عدد كبير من المفقودين وفي
مدينه دارنا قال المجلس البلدي ان السيول
سببها انهيار سدين في المدينه وطلب بفتح
ممر بحري واعلن المجلس البلدي المدينه
منطقه المنكوبه ودعا الى تدخل دولي عاجل
وفي مدينه البيضاء ذكر المركز الطبي في
المدينه ان عدد قتل السيول ارتفع الى سته
واربعين قتله
تضرب عاصفه اطلق عليها اسم دانيال ووصفها
الخبراء بانها ظاهره نادره من حيث كميه
المياه المتساقطه خلال 24 ساعه اليونان
لتتحرك من هناك عابره المتوسطه لتصل الى
ليبيا مست العاصفه مدن الساحل الشرقي
الليبي بسرعه رياح وصلت الى 70 كيلومترا
في الساعه وكان ابرزها درنا والبيضاء
وتكنس والمرج واجزاء من بنغازي وما يحيط
بهذه المدن من قرى ومناطق لكن وضع درنا
كان مختلفا ففي المدينه التي يشقها وادي
درنه بطول 50 كيلومترا تجمعت الامطار
الطوفانيه في الوار وارتفع مستواها شكل
ذلك ضغطا على السدين مائيين يحجزان المياه
فانهار وفق المجلس البلدي بذرنا مما جعل
الدمار اكبر مع امتداد الوادي وحتى وسط
المدينه وصولا الى البحر وهو ما رفع عدد
الضحايا المحتمرين خصوصا لساكنه على ضفاف
الوادي
من جانب اخر اورد التقارير ان السيول
سببها التفريغ المياه الفائضه عن القدره
الاستيعابيه للسد عبر المجرى المخصص لها
بوسط المدينه وافد لغياب معطيه كافيه
وحديث تقارير عن اعداد كبيره من الضحايا
بين قتلى ومفقودين جراء الفيضانات سرع
المجلس البلدي لمدينه درنه للحديث عن خروج
الاوضاع في المدينه عن السيطره مطالبا
بفتح ممر بحري اثر انهيار الطرق البريه
المؤديه اليها نعلم مدينه دارنا مدينه
منقوبه
وتحتاج الى تدخل دولي وتحتاج الى تدخل فتح
الممرات البحريه لان جميع الطرق التواصل
الواصله لمدينه درنه تعتبر طرق الى الان
مقطوعه لا يمكن الدخول لمدينه عن طريق
واحد وهو وهذا الطريق يعتبر لا يمكن
الوصول اليه بتلك السهوله عماره سكنيه
انهارت ومبان جرفتها المياه في درنه التي
اضحت مدينه منكوبه بشكل كامل كما اظهرته
مقاطع فيديو منتشره عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي يعلن جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ عن
وفاه عدد من الاشخاص في مدينه سوسه شرقي
مدينه درنه وفقدان العشرات لتزداد المخاوف
مع الوقت بارتفاع الحصيله التي تبقى غير
واضحه وغير محدده حتى تتبين خيوط الكارثه
كامله مدن البيضاء واشحات ومنطقه كندولا
جنوبيه الجبل الاخضر كانت بدورها عرضه
للفيضانات والسيول حديث عن عشره القتلى
ممن قضوا بسبب السيول مع توقع مدير مستشفى
البيضاء ان تكون الاعداد بالمئات وفي
الشمال الشرقي لليبيا والتحديدا في المرج
توفي عدد من الاشخاص وفقد اخرون جراء
السيول التي جرفت بيوتهم حصلت المياه درنه
بشكل كبير ولم تتكشف الصوره الكامله
لتابعه ما حدث ومع ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا
فيها وعدد من مدن ومناطق شرق ليبيا لم
تتمكن فرق الطوارئ من الوصول الى مئات
العائلات التي حاصرتها السيول
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه محمد حموده
في مقابرتهم مع الجزيره ان التقديرات
الاوليه لاعداد الضحايا جراء الفيضانات في
مناطق الشرق تصل الى المئات
هناك تضارب
والاحصائيات نظرا لانزال وقطاع التواصل في
عدد من المناطق
وصعوبه الوصول الى الى بعض البلديات جره
ثقافه الطرق الصدر ولكن
التقارير التي تطيرنا من خلال اللجنه
العليا للازمه عبر مركز الاتصال الذي
يتواصل بشكل مباشر
مع عملاء البلديات
والمخاتير المحلات فهي الاعداد عاده
في حدود المئات من الضحايا وايضا
يتم تخطيط رحلات من قبل الطيران المدني
الى مطار طبرق والابرق من اجل نقل الفرق
الاراده الطبيه بشكل عاجل
هذا هو طلب رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي من
الدول الصديقه والشقيقه تقديم المساعده
للمناطق المنكوبه لانتشال الضحايا وتامين
الامدادات الضروريه نتيجه الفيضانات
الكارثيه بينما اعلن الرئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد دبيبه الحداده ثلاثه
ايام على ضحايا السيول كما اعلن في اجتماع
طارئ للحكومه جميع البلديات التي تعرضت
للسيول مناطق منكوبه
قرار باعتبار جميع البلديات التي تعرضت
لهذه الكارثه والسيول مناطق منكوبه
موجها كافه الجهات العامه والخاصه
والمختصه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
والعاجله والاستثنائيه في مواجهه كافه
الاضرار في هذه الكارثه التي نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان لا تتكرر علينا
وامانه من طرابلس مراسله الجزيره احمد
خليفه ارقام يعني كارثيه من تاتي من الشرق
7000 مفقود 20,000 عائله مشرده كيف تبدو
هذه الكارثه وفق البيانات الصادره من
الحكومه وايضا من الجهات المعنيه في الشرق
السيوله التي والفيضانات التي جرفت مدينه
درنه زين العابدين كانت مدمره بشكل كبير
جدا لم تشهدها ليبيا من قبل في تاريخها
هذه المره الاولى التي تحدث فيها في
البلاد مثل هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه السيول
جرفت كل شيء في طريقها الاحياء السكنيه
سيارات المواطنين البشر جرفت كل ما وجدته
في طريقها الان في مدينه درنه يعكف الجميع
سواء كانوا من السكان المحليين او من
نشطاء المجتمع المدني او من الفرق فرق
الانقاذ والاغاثه والدعم والمساعده التي
توجهت من كافه مناطق البلاد من الشرق ومن
الغرب ومن الجنوب جميعها توجهت الى مدينه
درنه الان الجميع يعمل على احصاء الخسائر
البشريه والماديه وتقديم المساعدات اليوم
مساء الحكومه من هنا من العاصمه طرابلس
سيرت قوافل للمساعده والدعم ممثله في
وزاره الدفاع التي جهاز الطب العسكري
التابع لهذه الوزاره سياره قافله
للمساعدات والدعم في مقابل القافله اخرى
من وزاره الداخليه في مقابل قوافل الاخرى
من الجمعيات الاهليه ومنوشطاء المجتمع
المدني جميعهم توجهوا الى الشرق وتحديدا
الى مدينه درنه في محاوله
لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه وايضا في محاوله
لمساعده السكان المشكله زين العابدين يمكن
القول ان هناك مشكله حقيقيه في مساله دخول
مدينه درنه الدخول اليها صعب الطرق لم تعد
ممهده كما كانت من قبل لدخول المدينه
الطرق الرئيسيه المطله على الساحل ساحل
مدينه درنه انهارت بشكل كبير جدا شبه
انقطعت الطريق في هذه المنطقه
ايضا المناطق الصحراويه هناك الان محاولات
لهذه القوافل ولكل من يتجه الى مدينه درنه
ان يذهب الى مدينه طبرق التي تقع على
الحدود مع جمهوريه مصر ثم يعود الى مدينه
درنه عبر الطريق الواصل بين الطبق وبين
مدينه درنه اما الطرق الواقعه غرب مدينه
درنه وفي جنوبها فتقريبا شبه انهارت
بالكامل جرار قوه السيول والفيضانات التي
جرفت كل شيء في طريقها لما حدث كانت له
اصداء وتداعيات وردود فعل اقليميه ومحليه
ودوليه كبيره جدا من السفرات الاجنبيه في
ليبيا وايضا من قاده الدول في الخارج
الجميع ارسل التعازي وابدا الاستعداد
للمساعده وتقديم الدعم للضحايا كما فعل
الامير تميم امير قطر وايضا
بعض الدول الاخرى التي كالجزائر على سبيل
المثال وايضا كمصر وايضا حتى المغرب التي
عرضت المساعده وعرضت ان تقدم الدعم
والمساعده والخدمات خدمات الاسعاف احمد
خليفه من طرابلس مراسل الجزيره شكرا جزيلا
لك
من بنغازي ينضم الينا هشام ابو شكيوات
وزير الطيران المدني في الحكومه المكلفه
من البرلمان وعضو لجنه الطوارئ استاذ هشام
اهلا بك حسب معلوماتي انك ايضا زرتا
وتجولت في المناطق المنكوبه نريد ان ترسم
للمشاهد صوره
للوضع الان
سيد هشام
بما انك زرت المناطق المنكوبه واطلعت على
الواقع هناك نريد ان تنقل للمشاهد ما
شاهدته اليوم
للاسف غدا الاتصال بالسيد هشام بوشكوات
وزير الطيران البدنيه في الحكومه المكلفه
من البرلمان وعضو لجنه الطوارئ وينضم
الينا من مدينه البيضاء شرقيه ليبيا عبد
الرحيم مازق مدير مركز البيضاء الطبي وهو
المستشفى الحكومي الرئيسي في المدينه هذه
مناطق منقوبه انقل لنا سوره الواضع الصحي
في هذه المدن بعد هذه الفيضانات المدمره
وهذا العدد الكبير من المشردين
شكرا اخي الكريم
الطيبه لك ولجميع مشاهدين الكرام حقيقه
بدات الاعصار يضرب مدينه البيضاء ومناطق
شرق ليبيا ميدو
ظهر يوم الامس وكانت معدلات هطول الامطار
والرياح عاطيه جدا معدلاتكم بكميات كبيره
جدا جدا
لم تمر على المدن الليبيه متوفر من 40 سنه
والممتلكات والعائلات للاسف واصابات كبيره
جدا سواء في مدينه البيضاء او المدن
الجاهره انقطاع شبكه الكهرباء وانقطاع
خطوط الاتصال بالكامل
للاسف لها خروج مركز البضاعه الطبي عن
الخدمه تماما يوم امس نتيجه انهيار اجزاء
كبيره منه دخول نيابه كميات كبيره من
مقدار الفرق العامله بوحدات الصيانه على
فصل التيار الكهربائي بالكامل عن المستشفى
واجلاء المرضى الى
المستشفيات الخاصه للمدينه والى
المستشفيات الموجوده في مناطق مرتفعه
للاسف الاصابات كانت بالغه جدا كانت اكبر
من كل الامكانيات
عدم قدره الحكومه على مبلغ العون وعدم
قدره شقق الانقاذ على الوصول الى
المحاصرين داخل بيوتهم من جرفتهم السيول
فقدان العديد من العاملين في فرق للاسف
توفاهم الله وجهتهم ايضا بعد انحشار
المياه منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى لهذا
اليوم
للاسف الابرار
وبالغه جدا
وصل حتى هذه اللحظه الى مركز البيضاء
الطبي 46 جثه من توفاهم الله للاسف معظم
من اجتاح السيول كم البلاغ عليهم انهم
مفقودين ولم تجد شرقا انقاذ لهم اي اثر
حينما تتحدث الجهات المختصه في الشرق عن
7000 مفقود
هذا يعني انه هذا حصر بالبيوت التي لم يتم
الوصول اليها
نعم نعم وفقا لاحصائيه الاحياء والبيوت
اللي لم يتم الوصول اليها
السيول تشير التوقعات الاوليه الى حوالي
7000 في المنطقه الشرقيه بالكامل فقدوا
تماما هناك بعض الجثه بدات ترفع على سواحل
البحر الابيض المتوسط القريب وتم انتشالها
للاسف كم نقلها عن طريق هذه
وندعو الله بالسلامه لجميع المواطنين من
لم يتم التوصل اليهم ان يكونوا بصحه جيده
تعمل جاهده لكن للاسف امكانياتهم ضعيفه
جدا وعدم القدره على المرور عبر الطرقات
التي الطرقات المنطقه الشرقيه هي منطقه
جبليه جميع الطرقات انهارت بالكامل
الذين لم يتم الوصول اليهم والى مناطقهم
حتى الان بسبب هذه الظروف كم يقدر عدد عدد
هؤلاء سكان
مدينه البيضاء وما جوارها قد يصل العدد
الى حوالي
4,500 جاكم بالاضافه الى الكارثه الكبرى
حقيقيه في مدينه درنه حوالي المدينه
بالكامل كم من جرفها الى البحر
وتتحدث شيء احصائيات الاوليه الى فاقد ما
يزيد عن 5000 مواطن في مدير الدرنه فقط
فضلا عن عدم القدره في الوصول الى مدينه
داخل مدينه نتيجه التحكم الجسور المؤديه
الى المدينه وانسداد طرق اليها بالكامل
وانقطاع شبكه الكهرباء داخلها وعدمها على
التواصل معهم الاحصائيه كارثيه داخل مدينه
درنه وداخل الجبل الاخضر للاسف عدم وجود
اي قدره لانتشار الغارقين او المنطقه وهذا
ما يزيد من خطر زياد اعداد
المتوفين نشكرك شكرا جزيلا على هذه
المعلومات من مدينه البيضاء شرقي ليبيا
عبد الرحيم مازق مدير مركز البيضاء الطبي
وهو المستشفى الحكومي الرئيسيه في البيضاء
هذا المركز وحده كما قال ضيفنا وصله حوالي
46 جثه بعد قبل ان يخرج عن العمل بسبب
الانهيارات التي اسببتها الفيضانات
في ردود الفعل الدوليه قال نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده ان
المنظمه تدرك الحجم الكبير للاضرار في
ليبيا وانها على اهبه الاستعداد للاستجابه
وقضى نائب الممثل الامومي في ليبيا منسقه
الشؤون الانسانيه جورجيت جانين من وصفتهم
بالشركاء المحليين والوطنيين والدوليين في
ليبيا الى تقديم المساعده الانسانيه
العاجله للمتضررين من اعصار دانيال
وفي سياق ردود الفعل ايضا على هذه
الفيضانات في ليبيا قالت وكاله الانباء
القطريه الاميره دوله قطر الشيخ امين بن
حمد الثاني وجه بارسال مساعدات عاجله الى
المناطق المتاثره بالفيضانات والسيول في
ليبيا وفي تونس امر الرئيس الجمهوريه قيس
سعيد بالتنسيق العاجل مع السلطات الليبيه
من خلال تسخير الامكانيات البشريه
والماديه المناسبه للمساهمه في مواجهه
اثار الاعصار وفي الجزائر اكد بيان وزاره
الخارجيه كامله الاستعداد للوقوف الى جانب
الاشقاء الليبيين ومدهم بيد الدعم
والمساعده للتخفيف من الوطاه وتوابع هذه
الكارثه كما اعرب رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه
موسى فقي عن التضامن الكامل مع اسر
الضحايا والمفقودين ودعا الى تقديم الدعم
الدولي لجهود الاستجابه كما اعربت سفاره
الولايات المتحده في ليبيا عن تعاطفها مع
ضحايا الفيضانات واكلت انها على اطلاع على
التقارير التي تفيد بان السلطات الليبيه
من كل الاطراف تعمل معا على استجابه طارئه
مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه وفي العناوين
في اليوم الرابع لكارثه الزلزال بالمغرب
السلطات المغربيه تعلن ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
الى
1862 قتيلا اكثر من الفين
وخمسمائه مصاب والجهود تتسارع لفتح الطرق
سعيا لبلوغ المناطق المعزوله
عمليات الاغاثه التوجه لاعانه الاف
المتضررين وايوايه فرق طبيه ودعم لوجستي
تتجه للمنطقه برا وجوا والحكومه المغربيه
تكشف عن برنامج لتعويض واياء من فقدوا من
فقدوا مساكنهم جراء الزلزال
مئات القتلى الاعصار والسيول الشرقيه
ليبيا وتقارير تتحدث عن الاف المفقودين
والمجلس البلدي لمدينه دارنا يطالب بتدخل
دولي عاجل ويقول ان احياء سكنيه باكملها
غرقت بعد انهيار سدين وادبيبه يعلن
البلديات المتضرره مناطق منكوبه
السلام عليكم جهود مستمره اذا سائر للوصول
الى احياء تحت الركام في المغرب وفي اليوم
الرابع اعلنت الحكومه المغربيه ان عدد
القتلى ارتفع الى
1862 قتيلا والمصابين الى الفين وخمسمائه
فرق الانقاذ تسابق الزمن لانقاذ من يمكن
انقاذه وسط تحدياتنا ابرزها فتح الطرق
المقطوعه التي تحول دون الوصول الى بعض
المناطق المنكوبه
ينضم الينا من منطقه تحناوت في اقليم
الحوز مركز الزلزال مراسله الجزيره
المختار العلاوي المختار يبدو انك في
منطقه
الذين شردهم الزلزال انقل لنا الصوره من
حيث انت ومشاهداتك اليوم اليوم الرابع
للزلزال
نعم نحن نتواجد بالقرب من الطريق في هذا
الاتجاه تارودانت الى جنوب المغرب هذه
السيارات قادمه من تارودانت وفي الجهه
المقابله الطريق تؤدي الى مدينه مراكش
نحن نتواجد تحديدا في ضواحي مدينه
تحناوت
بالقرب من احد الدواوير الذي تعرض الى
الزلزال اصابات كبيره في المنازل التي
تهدمت كليا او جزئيا سكان هذا الدوار
تقريبا كلهم خرجوا الى الطريق
يبيتون في العراء خلال هذه الايام في
انتظار التوصل بحلول بالخيام في اطار
ان يتم اعاده الاصلاح او بناء منازلهم وفي
خصوصا وان المنطقه تعرضت الى زلزال قوي
الناس تعاني انقلبت حياتها راسا على عقب
الان التحدي ارتفاع انخفاض درجه الحراره
بات يطرح على هؤلاء خصوصا وانهم فقدوا
منازلهم فقدوا اغطيتهم فقدوا كل ممتلكاتهم
فتيحه احدى ساكنه الدوار فتيحه
السلام عليكم
اذن تغيرت الحياه معالم الحياه
انه فرق بين الانسان ان يعيش في بيته
معززا مكرما وان يعيشها في الشارع الان
المنازل هل تدخلون لها ام لا لا
بسيطه ولكن
بالتالي ما اهم المطالب الان فتيحه اليوم
في ظل هذا الواقع
نخاف نسكن في ذاك السكن ويطيح عليا حيث
ما نقدرش
ولكن ماشي بحال هذيك الخطره ولكن
الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله هذه الصوره
من هذا الواقع النساء الان موجودات
الانسان يحتاج الى ان ياكل هناك مبادرات
ايضا من المهم ان نشير الى انه سكان
الدوار قاموا بتوزيع المهام بينهم من اجل
الحرص على سير الحياه بشكل عام هنا الان
يتم اعداد وجبه
العشاء المقرونيه يتم اعدادها في ظل هذه
الظروف
السلام عليكم السلام لاباس مرحبا بكم
عندنا احنا محسنين
يتبرعون عليهم بالمواد الاساسيه يقومون
بشكل جماعي اليوم الوجبه ما هي الوجبه كيف
العمليه ديال الطياب عندكم
داخل
حتى حاجه الحمد لله الحمد لله ارواحنا
الحمد لله بخير وعلى خير والدراري الحمد
لله بخير وعلى خير ولكن احنا دابا جايه
الشتاء
يعني دابا ماشي في الصيف جايه البرد
وعندنا الدراري الصغار
هنايا
والحمد لله الخيام وما كاينينش الخيام ما
عندناش يعني يلاه دايرين هذا الشيء اللي
دايرين ما كاينينش الخيام وما كاين لا
غطاء لا فراش لا والو
اذا هذا هذا جزء من الصوره
سنلتقي ايضا باحد الشباب المتطوعين الذي
يقوم بجهود مع بقيه الشباب من اجل تسيير
وتنظيم الاحتياجات كيف تقومون بتوزيع
المهام هنا اول حاجه الحمد لله على كل حال
احنا راضيين باللي قدر علينا الله تعالى
والحمد لله على كل حال احنا شباب المنطقه
متطوعينو الماموريه للوصول للمساعدات
الاقصى منطقه الاقصى منطقه فيها متضررين
منطقه الدوار جماعه اغواطيم
تحنوتات
الحفاضات والحليب
ومن بعد المبيت حنا في الزنقه والبرد
والحمد لله على كل حال احنا عندنا الثقه
الكامله في بلادنا وعندنا الثقه الكامله
فينا احنا واقفين مع بلادنا وغادي نوقفوا
بحول الله
اذا اذا شهاده اخرى
حياتكم الان تغيرت المستوى النفسي كيف هو
الجانب النفسي الحمد لله احنا
الله سبحانه
انت كتشوف الناس
ديال الدراري الصغار والحمد لله على كل
حال الحمد لله الحمد لله على كل حال اذا
هذا جانب من الصوره اشير ايضا الى انه في
راينا الساعات الماضيه كان هناك دعم كبير
فيما يخص المستوى الدوله في بعض المناطق
هناك الجمعيات المجتمع المدني وايضا
الافراد الذين قاموا بتوزيع مساعدات في
الدواوير هنا الموجوده باقليم الحوس في
هذا الدوار طبعا الشيء اللافت منذ بدايه
الزلزال وحتى هو الرضا بقضاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وحمد الله كل الناس تبدا بحمد الله لكن من
الواضح انه المطلوب الان كما قال الشاب
حليب للاطفال
وخيام
لواءهم وايضا السيدات والنساء هذا الشيء
الناقص حتى الان تقريبا في معظم المناطق
التي تجولنا فيها مع مراسلينا اليوم لكن
شكرا لك من حناوت المختار العبدلاوي
كشف رئيس الحكومه المغربيه عزيز اخنوش عن
برنامج لتعويضي من دمرت منازلهم او تضررت
بسبب الزلزال قال اخنوش ان البرنامج سيكون
جاهزا خلال ايام وسيتضمن ايضا اجراءات
للاواء المؤقت للمتضررين
ان شاء الله
عن قريب غادي نعلموا على هذا العرض
بالنسبه للمواطنين
كذلك انه في هاد كاين واحد العدد ديال
التساؤلات انه الناس اليوم ما عندهاش
السكنى فين تمشي كذلك يعني
يبنيوه المنازل ديالهم يعني بعض الحلول
اللي يهمون المواطنين
في المغرب الزمن للعثور على ناجينا وتقديم
المساعده لمئات ممن فقدوا منازلهم بعد
ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال الذي ضرب قرى اقليم
الحوز يوم الجمعه الماضي
يتضائل الامل على سفوح جبال الاطلس لكنه
لا يتلاشى تماما بالعثور على احياء تحت
الركام
صحيح ان مرور الساعات يعني ارتفاع عدد
الموتى غير ان تكفيف فرق الانقاذ المغربيه
عمليات البحث وتوسيعها يعزز الامال بنجاه
عالقين
هذه الكتل الصخريه الضخمه المنهاره لا
تزعزع ثقه الاهالي في رؤيه احبائهم احياء
يرزقون وتلك رغبه يتقاسمها معهم افراد فرق
الانقاذ انفسهم ولاولئك وهؤلاء في زلزال
تركيا وسوريا قصص نجاه ملهمه
سباق محموم مع الزمن تخوضه فرق الانقاذ
المغربيه ومعها منقذون عرب ودوليون مجهزون
بمعدات كشف وكاميرات لاختراق فجوات صغيره
بين الركام تساعدهم كلاب مدربه لاكتشاف
الجثث والاحياء لكن جهود الانقاذ تصطدم
بعقبات هائله فبعض القرى الجبليه المنكوبه
لا يمكن للسيارات الوصول اليها وحتى
المروحيات لا تستطيع الهبوط في بعضها بسبب
الارتفاعات الشاهقه والتضاريس الوعره
ويعني ذلك تعذر اجلاء الذين يتم انقاذهم
الى المستشفيات الكبرى لتلقي العلاج
اللازم كما ان استخدام الجرافات والرافعات
يفاقم خطر الانهيارات الصخريه وقد يقضي
على احياء مفترضين تحت الانقاض ما يجعل
العمل اليدوي باستخدام المعاول اكثر امانا
لكن بطئا ايضا في اوضاع يعد فيها الوقت
بالثواني والدقائق الحياه في بعض القرى
انتهت تقريبا فالمباني الطينيه سويت
بالارض و تكاد مهمه فرق الانقاذ تنحصر
بانتشال الجثث خصوصا في قرى اقليم الحوز
مركز الزلزال حيث سجل اكثر من نصف القتلى
اما الناجون من الكارثه فالى الم الفقد
ووقع الصدمه تضاف فصول اخرى من المعاناه
هذه خيم اقامتها السلطات على عجل كمراكز
ايواء طارئه على الطرق وعلى تخوم المناطق
المنكوبه
تتظافروا هنا جهود الدفاع المدني والجيش
ومنظمات غير حكوميه في المغرب لاحتواء
الموقف غير ان الاحتياجات تتعاظم وعامل
الوقت يضغط اكثر فاكثر مع قرب حلول فصل
الشتاء في تلك المناطق الجبليه النائيه
المحتاجه لانشاء مساكن لائقه تؤوي الاهالي
وتقيهم قرا بات على الابواب
من مراكش عماد عبقري رئيس قسم جراحه
العظام والمفاصل بالمستشفى الجامعي محمد
السادس
ما الدور الذي تقوم به وزاره الصحه الان
في هذه الكارثه
مساء النور اولا وقبل كل شيء اود ان اتقدم
بخالص التعازيم لكل الاسره المغربيه التي
فقدت اقارب واحباء في هذا المصاب ولكن
نقول الا ما يرضي الله كتب الله قدر الله
وما شاء فعل بالنسبه
ما توفره الوزاره المعنيه
للعنايه بهذا
المصابين فقد منذ يوم الجمعه منذ بدايه
قدم المصابين للمستشفى الجامعي محمد
السادس قدمت اداره المستشفى وراءها
الوزاره المعنيه كل وسائل اللوجستيكيه من
معدات طبيه من ادويه من اطر طبيه وشبه
طبيه وتم تجنيد من غير مستشفى الجامعي
مستشفى العسكري
مستشفيات اخرى على المعدنيه مراكش
لاحتواء الموقف والحمد لله الامور كثير في
اتجاه الايجابي
وكل يوم يتم تتم عمليه جراحيه لكميه هائله
تهدف الى
اسعاف وتقديم الخدمات الجراحيه لهؤلاء
المصابين
ثم يتعلق بنوعيه الاصابات التي تصل اليكم
ما هي ومن اي مكان تصل
بالنسبه للاصابات هي مختلفه تتراوح ما بين
كدمات بسيطه الى كسور بالغه الخطوره حيث
ان المرضى ياتون في بعض الاحيان ماشي كسر
واحد ولكن
اربعه او خمسه كسور تتفاوت الخطوره منها
كسور مغلقه وكسور مفتوحه يعني انها
الجلد حتى هو فيه الجروح مما يصعب عمليه
الجراحيه
المرضى نستقبلهم من كل الاماكن مدينه
مراكش
بالنسبه
للباني
والمنشات التي هدمت في مدينه مراكش الى
اقصى الجبال منطقه
شيشاوه
تحنه كل مناطق المتضرره
نستقبل منها مصابين فيما يتعلق بمركز
الزلزال ايغيل هل وصلت اي اصابات من هذه
المنطقه وما طبيعتها
ام لم يصل شيء
نعم وصلت بعض اصابات منطقه
المصابين الذين توفاهم الله عز وجل والذين
بقوا على قيد الحياه فهما كيما قلت لك
يشتكون من قصور متفاوته الخطوره الحمد لله
ان العمليات الجراحيه التسريب
متسارعه لان الوقت نتكلم معك فيه احنا
باقيين في المستشفى باقي
عمليه كلها مفتوحه الحمد لله المعده
الطبيه كلها متوفره والامور تسير في جميع
والحمد لله هذا في مراكش لكن طبعا الوضع
مختلف في اقليم الحوز لكن من الملاحظه انه
عدد القتلى في هذا الزلزال اكبر بكثير من
عدد المصابين من واقع ما يصل اليكم هل
هنالك تفسير لذلك
في الحقيقه ما عنديش
اتوفر الان على اي معطيات ارقام لاننا من
الصباح واحنا
المهم يكون في العمليات ذلك ولكن اظن ان
نستقبل حالات اخرى تاتي كل ساعه تاتي كل
ساعه من حين اخر تاتينا اشاره ان هناك
سياره اسعاف قادمه الى مستعجلات نتاهب
لاستقبلها
نستعيد على مستوى المصانع الاستشفائيه
وعلى العمليات
لتقديم الخدمات الطبيه اللازمه في الساعات
الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه من اي منطقه
وصلت اليكم اغلب الاصابات والوفيات
الماضيه استقبلنا حالات من المناطق
القريبه لمراكش مثلا
اقليم شيشاوه
اوريكا
المناطق التي
متواجده بين اوريكا
هادو الاماكن اللي يستقبلنا منهم 24 ساعه
الماضيه شكرا جزيلا دكتور عماد عبقري رئيس
قسم جراحه العظامه والمفاصل بالمستشفى
الجامعي محمد السادس من مراكش
هذا ووصل الطائره القطريه الى المغرب على
متنها مساعدته الانسانيه وفريق انقاذ قطري
للمشاركه في جهود الاغاثه بالمناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال وقال الرائد خالد عبد
الله الحميدي قائد الفريق الانقاذ القطري
ان حضور الفريق جاء بعد تنسيق مسبق وتواصل
مع الجانب المغربي مضيفا ان افراد الفريق
القطري سيعملون كمساعدين للتوقم المغربيه
في موقعين بناء على ما تم الاتفاق عليه
عبر قنوات تواصل وتنسيق مع الجانب المغربي
هذا وبدات وحده الطوارئ التابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاسبانيه عملها في مدينه
امزايمز في اقليم الحوز للعثور على ناجينا
من الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه ونبه رئيس
الفريق الاسباني انطونيو الى ان المساكن
المتضرره من الزلزال مبنيه بالطوب الطيني
والحجر والخشب وهو ما يقلل من فرص العثور
على ناجين يشار الى ان الفريق الاسبانيه
يتالف من 56 فردا ومزود باربعه كلاب مدربه
للمساعده في جهود البحث والانقاذ
وعلى مدى الايام الماضيه شكل التضامن
الشعبي للمغاربه مع المتضررين من الزلزال
امرا لافتا وتفاعل المواطنون مع المبادرات
الشخصيه والمدنيه التي اطلقها افراد
ومشاهير في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من
خلال شراء كميات من المواد الغذائيه
والتمويليه وارسالها الى منكوب الزلزال في
المناطق المنكوبه
مثل الناس
وضع احد مشاهير مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في المغرب هذا النداء على حسابه الشخصي
فكانت هذه النتيجه
ما شاء الله شعبيه واستجابه فوريه اعداد
كبيره من المواطنين توجهوا الى احد مراكز
التسوق التجاريه كل حسب استطاعته وما جاد
به جيبه بتلقائيه وحماس بدا الامر وكانه
منسق قبل ايام وفي ظرف وجيز ملئت الشاحنات
والسيارات بالمساعدات قبل ارسالها الى
القرى النائيه او ما يعرف محليا بالدواوير
التي يعيش اهلها ظروفا انسانيه صعبه
الاولويه كانت للمواد الاساسيه التي شملت
الاكل والشراب والاغطيه والدواء الامر
نفسه تكرر في كثير من المدن المغربيه من
شمال المملكه الى جنوبها هناك اهم حاجه
وهي الانسانيه الحمد لله كاينه عند
المغاربه كلهم يعني الانسانيه هي الحاجه
اللي دفعتنا اننا نتعاونوا مع بعضنا
اخوتنا وقع لهم مشاكل غدا ممكن احنا يعني
احنا ما يكون فينا روح الانسانيه وروح
التضامن اننا نتعاونوا مع بعضياتنا في
الصغيره والكبيره والحكومه والشعب والسكان
كله متضامن ولله الحمد والمغاربه يعرفون
انه يعني
رحماء بينهم يضاف كل ما سبق من مبادرات
الى المشاركه الواسعه التي عبر عنها
المغاربه استجابه لمناشدات السلطات للتبرع
بالدم فمنذ الصباح الموالي للكارثه وحتى
الان ما زالت الامواج البشريه تصطف في
طوابير طويله انتظارا لدورها لتاديه ما
تراه واجبا لا منه
هكذا اذا هي الازمات تخرج دائما اجمل ما
في الانسان من صور التضامن والتكافل التي
وان كانت لن تحل المشكله بشكل نهائي
فلعلها تخفف ولو قليلا من هول ما حدث بعد
هذه الكارثه المفجعه وفك العزله عن هؤلاء
الذين لا حول لهم ولا قوه بعدما اخذ منهم
الزلزال كلما يملكون
ومعنى من مراكش الدكتور هشام خرموطي
الباحث في السياسات الطبيه بدايه ما هو
تقييمكم
للمجهودات الطبيه لاسعاف المصابين
وعلاجهم حتى الان هل هنالك وفره في
المنشات التي تقدم هذه الخدمه
الاستاذ العزيز بالفعل يعني تتضافر كل
جهود من اجله انجاح عمليه الاسعاف وتقديم
العلاجات الضروريه والاكيد ان يعني
التردد قدوم الحالات او الرتابه التي كانت
عليه في اليومين السابقين خفت حدتها هذا
اليوم سواء بالنسبه للاصابات الطفيفه او
بالنسبه للاصابات الجد حرجه وكذلك بالنسبه
للوفيات وهذا يعني من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
يعني لا زالت الطاقه الاستيعابيه يعني
قادره على تحمل المزيد وهذا يعني يشكل في
حد ذاته يعني انتصار مرحله جد مهم يعني
يجعلنا نتفائل في قادم الايام باحتواء هذه
الازمه هل هنالك حاجه لفتح منشات صحيه
سواء خاصه او عامه اضافيه ام ان المتاح
الان كافي
من طبيعه الحال يعني كل
المجهودات اللي ممكن يعني نقوم بها تتبقى
محموده في هذا الوقت والاكيد ان يعني
المستشفى الميداني تنشا يعني من طرف
القوات المساعده القوات المسلحه الملكيه
كان له الدور الكبير كذلك في اعطاء واحد
الدفعه وواحد النفعه النفحه ديال الامان
القاصده في المزيد وفي يعني في هذا الاطار
فتبقى جميع المجهودات جد محموده لا سيما
انه يعني
الحالات ليست فقط كلها قادمه من الاصابات
جراء الزلزال هناك عدد من الحالات يعني
الطبيه التي يعني تلزمها العنايه كذلك
والحمد لله انه تمت عوده يعني اطباء
القطاع الخاص كذلك للمزاوله وللاسهام كذلك
في حال حاله الاوضاع القائمه يعني هنالك
من يطالب بان تكون هذه هنالك مبادرات
بالفعل بان تكون هذه الخدمات من القطاع
الخاص بالمجان ما رايك
دعني يعني اكون صريحا معك هنا فيعني
الاكيد انه
معاينه في هذا الصباح لمجموعه من العيادات
الطبيه هناك عيادات يعني كثيره لاحقها
ضرر جراء الزلزال وخليني نفتح واحد القوس
هنا قصده يعني توجيه رسائل الشكر لاعوان
السلطه وكذلك لرجال السلطه الذين قدموا
يعني بكثافه قصده يعني تمشيط جميع
الاماكن السكنيه وبالتالي كان يعني كانت
المعاينه ديال الاضرار التي لحقت العيادات
ومن وبعد ذلك يعني تم توجيه مجموعه من
العيادات قصد الاقفال وخلينا نقول بان هذا
الامر هذا لم نستحسنه ولكن نظرا يعني
الشكل الحاصل في في يعني فيما خلف الزلزال
من ابرار لاحقت ببعض البنايات يجعلوننا
نتخلص من حدوث اي يعني كوارث الصيامه
الارتدادات لا زالت يعني
باقيه ولا زالت يعني ترخي بظلالها على هذا
المشهد يعني الاليم وهنا خليني نقول بان
العيادات التي بشرت يعني
خدماتها اتجاه المواطنين لاحظنا كثره
الحالات اللي تنسميهم
يعني النساء الحوامل مع الخلعه وهذا يعني
تعرضوا الاغلبيه تعرضت للنزيف هناك من
فقدت يعني جنينها وهناك من بقيت خائفه
وكانت تلزمها العنايه اللازمه وهذا الامر
هذا لاحظناه بشده في العيادات الطبيه
اليوم والحمد لله ان الاطباء قاموا
بالواجب وعاينوا عديد الحالات ويعني
الكثير منهم تبرع والكثير يعني نزل يعني
ممكن ان يجود
بسخائي يعني عدم يعني
التخلص
الواجبات ديال هذا الزيارات هذه والعديد
من الاطباء يؤمنون بادوارهم الاجتماعيه
وهذا يعني
وقت لمزيد من الرسائل القصده الاعتناء
بالمواطنين وعدم الانتباه الى كل الامور
الاخرى يعني هل تقول دكتور هشام هنالك
اقبال او ضغط على العيادات الخاصه الان
نظرا لان النظام الصحي مشغول في الواقع
بالكارثه الان
يعني الاغلبيه ديال الناس يحاولون ان
يجعلوا المستشفيات ويجعل المراكز الصحيه
يعني ان يتركوها لقصبه يعني
اسعافي المتضررين المباشرين من الزلزال
بالمقابل المرضى يعني اللي عندهم امراض
مزمنه واللي يعني التطورات الحاله ديالهم
يا اما جراء الصدمه يا اما جراء يعني
الهلع الذي اصابهم وكذلك بالنسبه للنساء
الحوامل فالاكيد انهم توجهوا للعيادات
الخاصه بشكل يعني
كثيف جدا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من مراكش دكتور
هشام خرمودي الباحث في سياسات الطبيه
هذا وتعرقل الطبيعه الجغرافيه الوعره
وعمليات البحث والانقاذ في مناطق واسعه
ضربها الزلزال في المغرب نتعرف على اكثر
على هذه الازمه وهذه المناطق وطبيعتها في
سياق هذا التقرير
وسط هذه الجبال يكمن التحدي مع تواصل
عمليات البحث عن الناجيين وانتشال الضحايا
تقف الجغرافيا عقبه صلبه امام الفرق التي
تعمل على مدار الساعه منذ اربعه ايام
الجغرافيه هنا هي سلسله جبال الاطلس
الممتده من المغرب غربا حتى تونس في
الشمال الشرقي عند قريه ايغيل باقليم
الحوز جنوبيه مراكش كانت نقطه ارتكاز
الزلزال تلك قريه صغيره على سفوح جبال
الاطلس تقول التقارير ان الزلزال مسحها عن
الوجود بالنظر الى مقاطع الفيديو من
المناطق القريبه التي وصلتها العدسات تظهر
البيوت القديمه والطبيعه الجغرافيه الصعبه
ما يشير الى امكانيه ان يمحو الزلزال فعلا
قرا بهذا الشكل في مثل هذه المناطق فاقليم
الحوز الممتد على مساحه سته الاف كيلو متر
مربع تقريبا تغطي الجبال ثلاثه ارباع
مساحته يضم نحو اربعين قريه وبلده مثل
ايغيل
بين هذه الجبال سبع درجات على مقياس ريختر
وصلت تاثيراتها على بعد 400 كيلو متر في
محيط المكان في المنطقه القريبه من ايغيل
بلده اديسيل تتبع اقليم شيشاوه المجاور
لكنها قريبه للغايه من مركز الزلزال قريه
جبليه سويت بالكامل وقطعت الانهيارات
الصخريه الطرق المؤديه اليها وتحولت الى
مثال حي للماساه يعقد الوضع في شيشاوه
بشكل عام المشهد في محيط مركز الزلزال
يعتبر الاقليم بموقعه الجغرافي ممرا
ضروريا لمناطق جنوب المغرب وغربا باتجاه
الصويره لكن على بعد 80 كيلومترا جنوبا من
مركز الزلزال يتكرر الضرر تارد انت مدينه
تلتقي فيها سلسله تاجبه للاطلس الصغير
والاطلس الكبير يتسبب الزلزال في حدوث
انهيارات صخريه في تارودانت
الى ليبيا وتعيش مدن الشرق فيها تحت وطاه
كارثه انسانيه بسبب السيول وفيضانات كانت
من تداعيات الاعسار دانيال واسفرت حسب
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عن ضحايا بالمئات
وقال الرئيس الحكومه المعينه من البرلمان
في شرق ليبيا ان عرض الضحايا يبلغ الفين
مع عدد كبير من المفقودين وفي مدينه درنه
قال المجلس البلدي ان السيول سببها انهيار
سدين في المدينه وطلب بفتح ممر بحري واعلن
المجلس البلدي والمدينه منطقه منقوبه ودعا
الى تدخل دولي عاجل وفي مدينه البيضاء ذكر
المركز الطبي في المدينه ان عدد القتلى من
السيول ارتفع الى سته واربعين
تضرب عاصفه اطلق عليها اسم دانيال ووصفها
الخبراء بانها ظاهره نادره من حيث كميه
المياه المتساقطه خلال 24 ساعه اليونان
لتتحرك من هناك عابره المتوسطه لتصل الى
ليبيا مست العاصفه مدن الساحل الشرقي
الليبي بسرعه رياح وصلت الى 70 كيلومترا
في الساعه وكان ابرزها دارنا والبيضاء
وتكنس والمرج واجزاء من بنغازي وما يحيط
بهذه المدن من قرى ومناطق لكن وضع درن كان
مختلفا ففي المدينه التي يشقها وادي درنا
بطول 50 كيلومترا تجمعت الامطار الطوفانيه
في الوار وارتفع مستواها شكل ذلك ضغطا على
السدين مائيين يحجزان المياه فانهار وفق
المجلس البلدي بذرنا مما جعل الدمار اكبر
مع امتداد الوادي وحتى وسط المدينه وصولا
الى البحر وهو ما رفع عدد الضحايا
المحتملين خصوصا لساكنه على ضفاف الوادي
من جانب اخر اورد التقارير ان السيول
سببها التفريغ المياه الفائضه عن القدره
الاستيعابيه للسد عبر المجرى المخصص لها
بوسط المدينه وفي ظل غياب معطيه كافيه
وحديث تقارير عن اعداد كبيره من الضحايا
بين قتلى ومفقودين جراء الفيضانات سرع
المجلس البلدي لمدينه درنه للحديث عن خروج
الاوضاع في المدينه عن السيطره مطالبا
بفتح ممر بحري اثر انهيار الطرق البريه
المؤديه اليها نعلم مدينه منقوبه
وتحتاج الى تدخل دولي وتحتاج الى تدخل فتح
الممرات البحريه لان جميع الطرق التواصل
الواصله لمدينه درنه تعتبر طرق الى الان
مقطوعه لا يمكن الدخول لمدينه عن طريق
واحد وهذا الطريق يعتبر لا يمكن الوصول
اليه بتلك السهوله عماره سكنيه انهارت
ومبان جرفتها المياه في دارنه التي اضحت
مدينه منكوبه بشكل كامل كما اظهرته مقاطع
فيديو منتشره عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يعلن جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ عن وفاه عدد
من الاشخاص في مدينه سوسه شرقي مدينه درنه
وفقدان العشرات لتزداد المخاوف مع الوقت
بارتفاع الحصيله التي تبقى غير واضحه وغير
محدده حتى تتبين خيوط الكارثه كامله مدن
البيضاء واشحات ومنطقه كندوله جنوبيه
الجبل الاخضر كانت بدورها عرضه للفيضانات
والسيول حديث عن عشره القتلى ممن قضوا
بسبب السيول مع توقع مدير مستشفى البيضاء
ان تكون الاعداد بالمئات وفي الشمال
الشرقي لليبيا والتحديدا في المرج توفي
عدد من الاشخاص وفقد اخرون جراء السيول
التي جرفت بيوتهم حصلت المياه درنه بشكل
كبير ولم تتكشف الصوره الكامله لتابعه ما
حدث ومع ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا فيها وعدد
من مدن ومناطق شرق ليبيا لم تتمكن فرق
الطوارئ من الوصول الى مئات العائلات التي
حاصرتها السيول
هذا وقال باسم حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه محمد حموده في مقابله مع الجزيره
ان التقديرات الاوليه لاعداد الضحايا جراء
الفيضانات في مناطق الشرق تصل الى المئات
هناك تضارب
والاحصائيات نظرا لانزال وقطاع التواصل في
عدد من المناطق
وصعوبه الوصول الى الى بعض البلديات جره
سقطت الطرق
ولكن
التقارير التي تصيرنا من خلال اللجنه
العليا للازمه عبر مركز الاتصال الذي
يتواصل بشكل مباشر
مع عملاء البلديات
والمخاتير المحلات فهي الاعداد عاده في في
حدود المئات في الضحايه وايضا
يتم تخطيط رحلات من قبل الطيران المدني
الى مطار طبرق ولابرك من اجل نقل الفرق
الاراده والاقم الطبيه بشكل عاجل
كما طلب رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي من
الدول الصديقه والشقيقه تقديم المساعده
للمناطق المنكوبه لانتشار الضحايا وتامين
الامدادات الضروريه نتيجه الفيضانات
الكارثه بينما اعلن رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه الحداده ثلاثه
ايام على ضحايا السيول واعلن في اجتماع
طارئ للحكومه جميع البلديات التي تعرضت
للسيول مناطق منكوبه
قرار باعتبار جميع البلديات التي تعرضت
لهذه الكارثه والسيول مناطق منكوبه
موجها كافه الجهات العامه والخاصه
والمختصه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
والعاجله والاستثنائيه في مواجهه كافه
الاضرار في هذه الكارثه التي نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان لا تتكرر علينا
احمد خليفه احمد نقف معك على اخر
المعلومات حول هذه الكارثه المناطق التي
طالتها عدد الضحايا المشردين المفقودين
السيول والفيضانات زين العابدين اجتاحت
كامل مدينه درنه ازالت احياء باكملها
عمارات سكنيه جرفت معها البشر الذين كانوا
موجودين داخل بيوتهم من سكان المدينه
وايضا من حتى الاجانب القاطنين فيها من
العماله الاجنبيه وغيرها
حجم الكارثه كبير جدا كما تؤكد مصادر
محليه من درنه ومن منطقه الجبل الاخضر
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه اتفقت في الوصف مع
الحكومه الموازيه في الشرق ليبيا بانهما
وصفتا مدينه درنه بانها مدينه منقوبه اخر
التطورات في هذا
الصدد منذ قليل نقلت وسائل اعلام تابعه
للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر عن وزير الصحه
في الحكومه الموازيه في شرق ليبيا انه
يتوقع ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا جراء هذه
السيول والفيضانات الى عشره الاف رغم ان
عمليات البحث ما زالت مستمره الان كل
الجهود في مدينه درنه تنصب او تصب في
اتجاه واحد وهو احصاء الخسائر البشريه
والبديه الجميع يبحث عن المفقودين ويبحث
عن الضحايا الموجودين تحت الركام جراء
السيول
والفيضانات
الاتصالات ما زالت مقطوعه في مدينه درنه
هناك فرق فنيه تحاول اعاده الاتصالات ايضا
الكهرباء مقطوعه بالكامل عن المدينه منذ
يوم امس وحتى قبل حدوث الفيضانات وقبل
اجتياح السيول للمدينه كانت عدد من احياء
المدينه قد قطعت عنها الكهرباء الان
الكهرباء مقطوعه عن المدينه بالكامل تحاول
الفرق الف
التابعه لشركه الكهرباء اعاده الكهرباء
الى المدينه وبالتالي ستعود معها
الاتصالات من جديد تغطيه الهواتف تعود من
جديد لكن حاليا يمكن القول ان مدينه درنه
من ناحيه الاتصالات والكهرباء مفصوله
تماما عن المناطق المحيطه بها شرقا وغربا
وجنوبا ايضا حتى
الطرق التي تؤدي الى المدينه وخصوصا من
مداخلها
الغربيه تحديدا للقادم من مدينه درنه من
غربها الطرق جرفتها قوه المياه ازاحتها
تماما هناك طرق انقطعت تماما
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه حتى في الدخول الى
مدينه درنه من يدخلون يحاولون الدخول عبر
الطريق الصحراوي بالذهاب الى مدينه طبرق
ثم الرجوع منها الى مدينه درنه والدخول
عليها من جديد ايضا
هناك قوافل مساعدات سواء على المستوى
الرسمي او على المستوى الشعبي ممثله في
قوافل الامداد ومساعده ودعم من الحكومه
هنا في العاصمه طرابلس ومن مؤسسات حكوميه
في مدن ومناطق المنطقه الغربيه وايضا
قوافل مساعدات ودعم من المنظمات المدنيه
في كامل انحاء البلاد جميعها وجهت تلك
القوافل الى مدينه درنه
والادويه والاغطيه وكل ما يلزم لاعاده
الحياه ولكل ما يلزم لاعاده
انقاذ الوضع هناك ودعم المدنيين الذين
يمكن القول ان بعضهم ما زال عالق داخل
المنازل رغم ان السيول توقفت تماما حتى
الاجواد اجواء الطقس في المنطقه الشرقيه
عاده تقريبا طبيعيه بشكل كبير جدا لكن
السيود التي اجتاحت المدينه كانت غير
مسبوقه في تاريخ البلاد وبالتالي كان حجم
الكارثه كبير جدا احمد خليفه من طرابلس
شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن بنغازي ينضم الينا هشام ابو شكوات
وزير الطيران المدني في الحكومه المكلفه
من البرلمان وعضو لجنه الطوارئ ونريد ان
نعرف منك الوضع في دارنا بالتحديد ما هي
المعطيات المتاحه لديكم عن الوضع في هذه
المدينه وكيف يعيش الاهالي الان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا لله وانا اليه
راجعون الذي جعل هذه الكلمات ملجا لاصحاب
المصائب مدينه درنه مدينه الصحابه مدينه
الازهار والازهار التي طالما تغنى بها
الادباء والفنيين والشعراء اليوم تعيش
كارثه امكانيه بمعنى الكلمه اليوم مدينه
درمه تفوح منها رائحه الموت في كل مكان
غطتها السيول والفيضانات في كل مكان مدينه
درنه اصبحت اليوم على انفجار
سجود المياه
لتاخذ معها كل المساكن في في طريقها
لتقدي تماما على بعض الاحياء وتنهيها من
الوجود هل هذا حدث ام تتوقع ان يحدث مساله
السدود
هذا حدث فجر هذا اليوم وترك وراءه اعداد
كبيره من الضحايا والوفيات العدد فيه
تزايد الكارثه كبيره بمعنى الكلمه المدينه
تعتبر مدينه منكوبه المنظر الذي رايته هذا
اليوم يفقد السيده الرئيس واعضاء لجنه
الطوارئ منظر يعني مريب هو نفس منظر تنامي
بالتحديد بالضبط يعني الوضع الكارثي بمعنى
الكلمه خلال الجوله بالطائره فوق المدينه
اليس كذلك
لا لا نحن دخلنا الى المدينه كنا من اول
الداخلين الى المدينه رفقه السيد الرئيس
واعضاء اللجنه وقوات المسلحه وزاره
الداخليه وهيئه السلامه المدنيه
وصلنا المدينه
وتعاملوا مع الحالات
وانتشار الجثث وكذلك حتى دفن الفيتامين
هذه كلها تولتها هذه المجموعه على راسها
الجيش الذي قافل المدينه وقسمها الى
مربعات واصبح يتعامل في انتشال الجثث
وانقاذ
المدنيين تحت انقاذ الوضع كارثي بمعنى
الكلمه يعني جزء من ملامح المدينه اختفى
تماما من على الوجود
اخذته
الاعاصير والمياه
وربى بها في البحر الحقيقه الوضع كارثي
بمعنى الكلمه
في المدينه كيف يعيشون اين منبقوا في
المدينه ولم تجرفهم السيول ماذا يفعلون
وما المساعدات التي تقدم اليهم
الجزء الذي تعرض للدمار هو الجزء الذي
قريب من مجرى الوادي هو الجزء الذي تعرض
للدمار وهو يقدر بحوالي 25% من مساحه
المدينه هو هذا تدمر دمرا شاملا اما باقي
المدينه فهي دخلت اليها المياه للمنازل
وتوجد بها الكهرباء ولا يوجد بها
الاتصالات فهي تعيش وضع يعني كارثه بمعنى
الكلمه
الناس في وضع كئيب في وضع حزين في وضع
متفاجئون يعني بالذي حدث يعني في ساعات
انقلبت حياته امراه على عقب الحقيقه الوضع
كارثي بمعنى الكلمه المطلوب مع هذه
الكارثه ما هي المساعدات المطلوبه ما هي
الاحتياجات الانيه الان وكيف يمكن ان تصل
من اي طريق يمكن ان تصل الى المدينه
ايضا ينضم الينا توفيق الشكر للمتحدث باسم
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر اللي بيقول عليك
استمعت الى مقاله السيد ابو شكوات
ما المعلومات المتاحه لديكم في جمعيه
الهلال الاحمر عن الوضع في الشرق الليبي
عموما وفي دارنا خصوصا
بدايه ما نعزي انفسنا ونعزي اهالي الضحايا
جواهر السيول بشكل عام وبشكل خاص متطوعين
الهلال الاحمر الليبي فقدنا اثنين من
متطوعين الاحمر الليبي الابطال اثناء
تقديمه تقديمهم للاعمال الانسانيه
واخلاء العالقين في مدينه درنه الوضع جدا
كارثي
جرفتهم السيول ام انهارت عليهم مباني مثلا
نعم اثناء
اثناء اخلائهم للعابدين جرفتهم والسيول
اصبحوا مفقودين لساعات
ولكن لا تم العثور بكل اسف على جثتهم
حاليا الذين
اخرين من المتطوعين
جاري البحث عن عنهم بالاضافه الى البحث عن
المفقودين التي سجلوا في السجلات الهلال
الاحمر الليبيرات
خمس احياء دمرت بالكامل في مدينه درنه
بوضع جدا كارثي الوضع في البيضه او في
مدينه البيضاء التي تبعد عن البيع عن دمنه
تقريبا 100 كيلو يعتبر الوضع احسن من امس
ولكن لا زال الوضع حتى هو
يعانون منهم المدينه طيب فيما يتعلق
باعداد المفقودين واعداد القتل الذين
توسقتم من العثور على جثثهم
والمصابين هل لديكم ارقام
نهائيه حتى هذه اللحظه او حتى ارقام
تقديريه
بالنسبه للمفقودين يقدر حسب الله سجلات من
كافه
الفروعيه الهلال الاحمر الليبي قرابه التي
تساعد الطلاق حتى هذه اللحظه اما بخصوص
عذرا كم الف عدد المفقودين
عدد الجفانين حسب ما ذكرت الحكومه
حتى هذه الساعه
نحن نجد صعوبه في تحديث المعلومات مع
فرقنا في الميادين في المناطق المنكوبه
نتيجه انقطاع الانترنت
وقطاع
وسائل الاتصال وكذلك قطاع الكهرباء
هل هل تمارسون اي دور الان داخل مدينه
درنه ما الذي يفعله الى الاحمر والطواقم
الطبيه في المدينه الان
جاري البحث مركز العمل جاري البحث عن
المفقودين
المسجلين في السجلات الهلال الاحمر الليبي
كذلك تقديم المساعدات التي تصل لجمعيه
البلاد الاحمر الليبي للعائلات المتضرره
جراء هذه السيول هل لديكم رقم للمفقودين
في درنا
الى الان
رقم يعني تقريبي بالضبط يعني نتيجه صعوبه
الاتصال هذه الارقام التي يزود بها حضرتك
هي تقريبا الساعه الرابعه مساء نتيجه
صعوبه الاتصال والتواصل مع الفرق
لن تصل الينا اخر التحديثات ما هو المطلوب
الان يعني لمن يريد ان يساعد ولا شك ان
الشعب الليبي كله يريد ان يساعد فما
المطلوب تقديمه الان
بصوره عاجله
المطلوب تكاثف الجميع وهو ما نجده حاليا
بالساحات الميادين سواء كانت
التكاثف الدولي والمحلي
ما يحتاجه لهذه الاحمر الليبي هو بالدرجه
الاولى السيارات الدفع الرباعي حتى يتمكن
من الوصول الى ابعد نقاط والبحث عن
المفقودين لعل يكون احدهم ناجي ولكن صعب
انه هو يرجع نتيجه السيول
الموجوده بالمدينه بالاضافه الى
الاحتياجات الطبيه من الادويه ومعدات
الاسعاف كذلك
اللقاء الغذائيه الغذائيه التي تقدم
للعائلات المنكوبه والتي
حصلت بيوتها حسب الارقام المسجله على
احصائيات الهلال الاحمر الليبي اكثر من
480 منزل هدما بالكامل
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من بنغازي توفيق الشكري
المتحدث باسم جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الليبي
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه قال نائب المتحدث
باسم الامين العاملي للامم المتحده ان
المنظمه تدرك الحجم الكبير للاضرار في
ليبيا وانها على اهبه الاستعداد للاستجابه
ودعت نائبه الممثل الوهميه في ليبيا منسقه
الشهود الانسانيه
والوطنيين والدوليين في ليبيا الى تقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله للمتضررين من
اعصار دانيل
وفي سياق ردود الفعل ايضا على الفيضانات
في ليبيا قالت وكاله الانباء القطريه ان
اميره دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
وجهها بارسال مساعده عاجله الى المناطق
المتاثره بالفيضانات والسيول في ليبيا
وفي تونس امر رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد
بالتنسيق العاجلي مع السلطات الليبيه من
خلال تسخير الامكانيات البشريه والماديه
المناسبه للمساهمه في مواجهه اثار الاعصار
وفي الجزائر اكد بيان وزاره الخارجيه
كامله الاستعداد للوقوف الى جانب الاشقاء
الليبيين ومدهم بيد الدعم والمساعده
للتخفيف من الوطاه وتوابع هذه الكارثه كما
اعرب رئيس المفوضات الافريقيه موسى فكي عن
التضامن الكامل مع اسر الضحايا والمفقودين
وداعا الى تقديم الدعم الدولي لجهود
الاستجابه واعربت سفاره الولايات المتحده
في ليبيا عن تعاطفها بعد حي الفيضانات
مؤكدت انها على اطلاع على التقارير التي
تفيد بان السلطات الليبيه من كل الاطراف
تعمل على توفير استجابه طارئه للكارثه
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوقف جارنت ايران
في جنوب لبنان من اجل ما وصفها باهداف
ارهابيه وقال جالنت خلال مؤتمر لمعهد
سياسه مكافحه الارهاب بجامعه رخمه في هيرت
سيليا الشماله تل ابيب ان المطاره يبعد
عشرين كيلو مترا فقط عن الحدود
الاسرائيليه حسب تعبيره
اود ان اكشف هنا لاول مره عن صور مطار في
جنوب لبنان تقوم بانشائه ايران في قلعه
جبور جنوبي البقاع وذلك لاهداف ارهابيه
المدرج طويل ويمكن ان تهبط فيه طائرات
متوسطه الحجم في هذه الصوره الثانيه
بالامكان رؤيه علمين علم حزب الله ومن غير
المستغرب العلم الايراني على الاراضي
اللبنانيه وذلك على بعد 20 كيلومترا من
الحدود مع اسرائيل اذا جرنا لبنان وحزب
الله الى حرب او الى مواجهه فانهما
سيدفعني ثمنا باهظا جدا
قلت وكاله نقلا عن مصادر امريكيه مطلعه
الى اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ما
هدت الطريقه لتنفيذ صفقه مع ايران تقضي
بتبادل السجناء واضافت المصادر النيران
وافقت على الافراج عن خمسه مواطنين
امريكيين محتجزين لديها مقابل سماح واشنطن
للبنوك الدوليه بتحويل 6 مليارات سته
مليارات دولار من الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده من كوريا الجنوبيه الى قطر دون
خوف من العقوبات الامريكيه
وبالمقابل وافقت اداره بايدن ضمن الاتفاق
على اطلاق سراح خمسه مواطنين ايرانيين
محتجزين في الولايات المتحده
وافادت رويترز نقلا عن وثيقه اطلعت عليها
الى ان افادت بان بلينك اصدر استثناء من
العقوبات الامريكيه للسماح بنقل الاموال
الايرانيه المجمده من كوريا الجنوبيه الى
دوله قطر
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجات الايرانيه ان
بلاده متفائله بان تبادل السجناء مع
الولايات المتحده سيتم في المستقبل القريب
وعرب عن امره في الانتهاء من عمليه نقل
الاموال الايرانيه التي تم تحريرها خلال
الايام المقبله حسب تعبيره
م اكدنا اننا مستعدون لتبادل السجناء لان
الموضوع انسان بالنسبه لنا وكان من الممكن
ان يتم تبادل السجناء في وقت سابق لو لم
تربط الولايات المتحده هذا الملف بالملفات
الاخرى متفائلون بان يتم التبادل السجناء
في المستقبل القريب في اطار التفاهم الذي
توصلنا اليه وفي موضوع الاموال المجمده
الايرانيه التي تم تحريرها نتوقع ان ننتهي
من نقلها خلال الايام المقبله وسنكون
قادرين على شراء السلع والبضائع غير
الخاضعه للعقوبات
اعرب اعضاء مجلس الامن عن دعمهم لعمليه
السلام التي تقودها الامم المتحده
والقائمه على المرجعيات المتفق عليها
واكدوا مجددا على الحاجه الملحه لحوار
يمني يمني ووقف شامل لاطلاق النار كما اكد
اعضاء المجلس مجددا على اهميه تحقيق تقدم
سريع وملموس في المناقشات الحاليه وشددوا
على الحاجه للحفاظ على الهدوء السائد
وضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق
اعضاء المجلس يرحبون بجهود وفدي السعوديه
وعمان ودعمهم المستمر جهود الوساطه التي
تقوم بها الامم المتحده
هذه تغطيه مستمره الان مع سلمى